are you working to a lower standard?
I don't believe so, and I've always been encouraged
by something that Charles Eames said.
He said he was conscious of working
within constraints,
but not of making compromises.
The distinction between a constraint
and a compromise is obviously very subtle,
but it's very central to my attitude to work.
Remember this reading experience?
The phone book. I'll hold the slide
so you can enjoy the nostalgia.
This is from the mid-'70s early trials
of Bell Centennial typeface I designed
for the U.S. phone books,
and it was my first experience of digital type,
and quite a baptism.
Designed for the phone books, as I said,
to be printed at tiny size on newsprint
on very high-speed rotary presses
with ink that was kerosene and lampblack.
This is not a hospitable environment
for a typographic designer.
So the challenge for me was to design type
that performed as well as possible
in these very adverse production conditions.
As I say, we were in the infancy of digital type.
I had to draw every character by hand
on quadrille graph paper --
there were four weights of Bell Centennial —
pixel by pixel, then encode them raster line by raster line
for the keyboard.
It took two years, but I learned a lot.
These letters look as though they've been chewed
by the dog or something or other,
but the missing pixels at the intersections
of strokes or in the crotches
are the result of my studying the effects
of ink spread on cheap paper
and reacting, revising the font accordingly.
These strange artifacts are designed to compensate
for the undesirable effects of scale
and production process.
At the outset, AT&T had wanted
to set the phone books in Helvetica,
but as my friend Erik Spiekermann said
in the Helvetica movie, if you've seen that,
the letters in Helvetica were designed to be
as similar to one another as possible.
This is not the recipe for legibility at small size.
It looks very elegant up on a slide.
I had to disambiguate these forms
of the figures as much as possible in Bell Centennial
by sort of opening the shapes up, as you can see
in the bottom part of that slide.
So now we're on to the mid-'80s,
the early days of digital outline fonts,
vector technology.
There was an issue at that time
with the size of the fonts,
the amount of data that was required to find
and store a font in computer memory.
It limited the number of fonts you could get
on your typesetting system at any one time.
I did an analysis of the data,
and found that a typical serif face
you see on the left
needed nearly twice as much data
as a sans serif in the middle
because of all the points required
to define the elegantly curved serif brackets.
The numbers at the bottom of the slide, by the way,
they represent the amount of data
needed to store each of the fonts.
So the sans serif, in the middle,
sans the serifs, was much more economical,
81 to 151.
"Aha," I thought. "The engineers have a problem.
Designer to the rescue."
I made a serif type, you can see it on the right,
without curved serifs.
I made them polygonal, out of straight line segments,
chamfered brackets.
And look, as economical in data as a sans serif.
We call it Charter, on the right.
So I went to the head of engineering
with my numbers, and I said proudly,
"I have solved your problem."
"Oh," he said. "What problem?"
And I said, "Well, you know, the problem
of the huge data you require for serif fonts and so on."
"Oh," he said. "We solved that problem last week.
We wrote a compaction routine that reduces
the size of all fonts by an order of magnitude.
You can have as many fonts on your system
as you like."
"Well, thank you for letting me know," I said.
Foiled again.
I was left with a design solution
for a nonexistent technical problem.
But here is where the story sort of gets interesting for me.
I didn't just throw my design away
in a fit of pique.
I persevered.
What had started as a technical exercise
became an aesthetic exercise, really.
In other words, I had come to like this typeface.
Forget its origins. Screw that.
I liked the design for its own sake.
The simplified forms of Charter
gave it a sort of plain-spoken quality
and unfussy spareness
that sort of pleased me.
You know, at times of technical innovation,
designers want to be influenced
by what's in the air.
We want to respond. We want to be pushed
into exploring something new.
So Charter is a sort of parable for me, really.
In the end, there was no hard and fast causal link
between the technology and the design of Charter.
I had really misunderstood the technology.
The technology did suggest something to me,
but it did not force my hand,
and I think this happens very often.
You know, engineers are very smart,
and despite occasional frustrations
because I'm less smart,
I've always enjoyed working with them
and learning from them.
Apropos, in the mid-'90s,
I started talking to Microsoft
about screen fonts.
Up to that point, all the fonts on screen
had been adapted from previously existing
printing fonts, of course.
But Microsoft foresaw correctly
the movement, the stampede
towards electronic communication,
to reading and writing onscreen
with the printed output as being sort of secondary
in importance.
So the priorities were just tipping at that point.
They wanted a small core set of fonts
that were not adapted but designed for the screen
to face up to the problems of screen,
which were their coarse resolution displays.
I said to Microsoft, a typeface designed
for a particular technology
is a self-obsoleting typeface.
I've designed too many faces in the past
that were intended to mitigate technical problems.
Thanks to the engineers, the technical problems went away.
So did my typeface.
It was only a stopgap.
Microsoft came back to say that
affordable computer monitors
with better resolutions
were at least a decade away.
So I thought, well, a decade, that's not bad,
that's more than a stopgap.
So I was persuaded, I was convinced,
and we went to work on what became Verdana
and Georgia,
for the first time working not on paper
but directly onto the screen from the pixel up.
At that time, screens were binary.
The pixel was either on or it was off.
Here you see the outline of a letter,
the cap H,
which is the thin black line, the contour,
which is how it is stored in memory,
superimposed on the bitmap,
which is the grey area,
which is how it's displayed on the screen.
The bitmap is rasterized from the outline.
Here in a cap H, which is all straight lines,
the two are in almost perfect sync
on the Cartesian grid.
Not so with an O.
This looks more like bricklaying than type design,
but believe me, this is a good bitmap O,
for the simple reason that it's symmetrical
in both x and y axes.
In a binary bitmap, you actually can't ask
for more than that.
I would sometimes make, I don't know,
three or four different versions of a difficult letter
like a lowercase A,
and then stand back to choose which was the best.
Well, there was no best,
so the designer's judgment comes in
in trying to decide
which is the least bad.
Is that a compromise?
Not to me, if you are working
at the highest standard the technology will allow,
although that standard may be
well short of the ideal.
You may be able to see on this slide
two different bitmap fonts there.
The "a" in the upper one, I think,
is better than the "a" in the lower one,
but it still ain't great.
You can maybe see the effect better
if it's reduced. Well, maybe not.
So I'm a pragmatist, not an idealist,
out of necessity.
For a certain kind of temperament,
there is a certain kind of satisfaction
in doing something that cannot be perfect
but can still be done to the best of your ability.
Here's the lowercase H from Georgia Italic.
The bitmap looks jagged and rough.
It is jagged and rough.
But I discovered, by experiment,
that there is an optimum slant
for an italic on a screen
so the strokes break well
at the pixel boundaries.
Look in this example how, rough as it is,
how the left and right legs
actually break at the same level.
That's a victory. That's good, right there.
And of course, at the lower depths,
you don't get much choice.
This is an S, in case you were wondering.
Well, it's been 18 years now
since Verdana and Georgia were released.
Microsoft were absolutely right,
it took a good 10 years,
but screen displays now do have
improved spatial resolution,
and very much improved photometric resolution
thanks to anti-aliasing and so on.
So now that their mission is accomplished,
has that meant the demise
of the screen fonts that I designed
for coarser displays back then?
Will they outlive the now-obsolete screens
and the flood of new web fonts
coming on to the market?
Or have they established their own
sort of evolutionary niche
that is independent of technology?
In other words, have they been absorbed
into the typographic mainstream?
I'm not sure, but they've had a good run so far.
Hey, 18 is a good age for anything
with present-day rates of attrition,
so I'm not complaining.
Thank you.
(Applause)